the president already has a lot on the
line with tonight's State of the Union
address he'll face a newly energized
Democratic House majority for the first
time 10 days before the deadline for
another possible government shutdown
major Garrett is at the White House
following preparations for the speech
major good morning good morning
so John one of the things we've been
talking about is the president wants to
emphasize unity strength a solid economy
but what does this idea this concept of
a unity mean well quite practically for
this White House it means finding a way
to avoid a second partial government
shutdown how do you do that you get some
money from House Democrats and Senate
Democrats on border security that means
some kind of barrier is it a wall
probably not no one wants to call that
anymore not even the president it's some
sort of reinforced area in some aspects
of the border that the president can
live with and that Democrats can live
with and I will tell you John there is
some tiny degree of optimism here at the
White House that that can be achieved
tonight's speech will try to create some
momentum for that so if the president is
still working on negotiations major
where does the idea of declaring an
emergency
stand it stands as a threat but one that
has less and less potency privately and
for a few Republicans publicly a lot of
push back for the president on this so
the emphasis is on working with Congress
getting some sort of funding that both
sides can live with and getting it
sooner rather than later
we keep hearing the president's going to
send a message of unity tonight major
what does that look like well it means
averting a second government shutdown
and also talking about issues that have
long been discussed in Washington with
bipartisan support lowering prescription
drug costs there's that old chestnut
infrastructure is always around never
seems to get resolved you'll hear
comments about that and keeping the
economy going the president will say a
strong US economy is by itself a
unifying force you'll hear a lot about
that tonight major I don't know lose
sight of this new Pentagon report that
is out that says Isis could be back
within six months in Syria
what are we likely to hear about the
president talking about that troop
withdrawal there which many of them his
own party opposed exactly nearly
defeated but not entirely defeated and
you'll hear from the president that he
wants to pull troops
wants to bring them back home but also
wants to achieve victory specifically
over Isis probably some more tempered
rhetoric there than we heard a couple of
weeks ago when the president was
declaring absolute victory and major
we're talking about the State of the
Union a lot of people are questioning
the state of the administration now with
the recent leaks of the president's
schedule really unprecedented what is
going on when inside this administration
what leaks are a common occurrence here
and they are destabilizing I asked two
senior administration officials
yesterday was this kind of like a four
alarm fire in terms of creating chaos
both said no it's more like burned
microwave popcorn well that's not good
well as long as that you look at it as
long as that's done that burning of the
popcorn on executive time then that's
alright